>> Sean: JOINING US AGAIN
LIVE FROM AUSTIN, TEXAS, FOX
NEWS CORRESPONDENT AT LARGE
GERALDO RIVERA.
HE IS WITH THE CHIEF OF THE
AUSTIN POLICE DEPARTMENT,
BRIAN MANLY.
SEND MY THANKS AND MY HIGH
REGARD TO HIM, HIS DEPARTMENT
AND ALL THE F.B.I. GUYS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT, PLEASE.
>> THE CHIEF CAN HEAR YOU,
SEAN.
BUT LISTEN TO WHAT GOVERNOR
GREG ABBOTT SAID.
THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS SAID.
"IN MY TIME, 1 YEARSES A
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF TEXAS AND
THREE YEARS AS GOVERNOR I HAVE
NOT SEEN A BETTER JOB THAN
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN FROM THIS
POLICE CHIEVE AND THE AUSTIN
POLICE."
CONGRATULATIONS, CHIEF.
JOB WELL DONE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I GOT TO SAY, THOUGH, THOSE
ARE HIGH PRAISE FROM THE
GOVERNOR, BUT I WAS SURROUNDED
BY A TEAM OF OFFICERS MEN AND
WOMEN I SPENT MY ENTIRE CAREER
WITH.
AND THE FEDERAL AGENTS THAT
JOINED US FROM THE A.T.F.,
F.B.I. AND THE POSTAL SERVICE.
WE HAD A TEAM THAT WAS
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
BRINGING THIS TO AN END AND TO
RESTORE PEACE TO AUSTIN.
THIS WAS A HUGE TEAM EFFORT.
>> CUT RIGHT TO THE HEADLINE,
THE STUNNING STATEMENT THAT
YOU MADE DURING THE BIG PRESS
CONFERENCE THAT YOU HAVE A
25-MINUTE VIDEOTAPE
CONFESSION, I GUESS YOU WOULD
SAY FROM CONDITT, FROM THE
23-YEAR-OLD BOMBER.
>> WE UNCOVERED A RECORDING HE
MADE ON HIS PHONE.
IT IS A VIDEO RECORDING IT'S
IN DARKNESS SO YOU DON'T SEE
ANYTHING BUT IN THE RECORDING
HE TALKED ABOUT THE AUSTIN --
ABOUT THE ACTION IN AUSTIN AND
THE SIX BOMBS AND THE BOMBS
THAT HE DETONATED AND KILLED
HIMSELF IN THE INTERACTION
WITH THE S.W.A.T. TEAM.
JUST TALKS ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HIS LIFE.
ANYTIME THERE IS SOMETHING
LIKE THIS, PEOPLE WANT A
MOTIVE, THEY WANT A REASON,
THEY BAPT -- WANT TO KNOW WHY.
THERE IS NO REASON.
WE TRYING TO ASSIGN
RATIONALITY TO AN IRRATIONAL
ACT.
CHILLING INSIGHT INTO THIS.
>> BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE A WOE IS
ME, A NARCISSISTIC PUNK WHO
KILLS TWO INNOCENT PEOPLE AND
WOUNDS FIVE OTHERS, TERRORIZES
THIS COMMUNITY.
IT'S ALL ABOUT HIM.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> WELL, I THINK FOR US IT WAS
THE VALUE OF THIS.
IT WAS VALUABLE TO US FROM THE
STANDPOINT THAT HE DESCRIBED
SIX BOMBS IN ENOUGH DETAIL TO
WHERE WE FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
HE BUILT ALL SIX BOMBS.
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH THERE WERE
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN ALL SIX
THERE WERE THINGS THAT
DISTINGUISHED THEM WE NEVER
RELEASED.
BY HIS OWN ADMISSION, IT MADE
IT CLEAR HE UNDERSTOOD WHAT
THOSE DIFFERENCES WERE AND
MADE US CONFIDENT HE BUILD
THOSE.
>> YOU KNOW, SEAN, ONE OF THE
IRONIC THINGS IS HE
COORDINATED THIS MASSIVE
EFFORT FOR FEDERAL, STATE AND
LOCAL AND HE IS ONLY THE
INTERIM, THE ACTING CHIEF.
WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO GET THE
JOB?
>> YOU KNOW, I HAVE HAD
BLESSINGS OF BEING WITH THE
AUSTIN POLICE DEPARTMENT FOR
28 YEARS.
THESE ARE MEN AND WOMEN I
CONSIDER MY FAMILY AND I
ENJOYED EVERY SINGLE DAY.
IF THE DECISION IS MEANT TO
BE, IT WILL BE.